[Musica]
grazie avere grazie domenica è più il 2
per cento impossible playnow bene sono
proprio contento di giocare in the good
the main ma che bello un livello nuovo
che non ho mai giocato però non vinco lo
stesso va bene ragazzi siamo tornati
serpente la vita non registrava michia
d'appello non registrava mente in modo
che posso livello vado a controllare
comunque è stata un periodo quasi il
triplo 7 su ogni cosa
e stato un periodo bellissimo questo
perché non registra ora tris da un 1000
anni è fantastico cioè l'ultima volta
che ho fatto il problema non contando
quello da bendato con quel mattacchione
di pietro e andiamo a vedere quanto
cazzo fatto tutti a molte quanto e
quante volte mi sono inventato altre
robe per non farete
eccolo a due mesi fa cioè da luglio mio
faccio una vita bellissima che peccato
che a monte i muslims a me mica
diventato sky nel frattempo è che in
questi due mesi incredibili per riesco
neanche a scendere quel problema
ok devo passare dalla montagna all'altra
beccarino è migliorato nel tempo il suo
gioco manovale
a parte le testate che tirano un ciak e
colore
permesso le due palle ce l'abbiamo
sempre noi uomini grazie ragazzo di e
naturalmente proprio devo stare più in
astinenza non facciamo che la prossima
volta passano quattro mesi diciamo che
raddoppiano sempre dortmund è che se 90
ok la madonna che prese col culo
all'aria ragazzi che minchia di livello
e grande rock
ok bene voglio vedere sparato cannone ma
dove
ma dove a vigo vada sono studiato
benissimo suo livello
raga un livello fatto bene su mac
potrebbe essere rare la rivolta per
questo gioco pensio sì ma finirà maisto
livello come motiva così tutta la vita
io domani all appuntamento dal dentista
io posso stare tutto il giorno
arcavacata ma mi devi sparare anche per
favore traguardo non ne posso già più
bello accaparra aggrapparsi alla corda
del lecce non è un problema per me il
problema è che non riesco a capire dove
stiamo andando a finire
e da un po
[Musica]
106 secondi della mia vita ha spesi in
questo gioco quando potevo militari di
choc
si chiama bazooka quello zio comunque va
bene anche full version salva turbo che
io sono stata in questo militare come si
sta c c è la madonna se così questo e
bazooka come scusa
pensa che mira di merda click to win
sempre comunque un gioco miliardi kof
duty ragazze 38 il flip biobottle flip
che era una vita che non lo faceva col
voto 5 lo dicano poi che mi piacciono
mai niente qui sono di centro c'è un
pallone prove è 11 l'ho fatto bene sono
proprio bravo nei bot
flipboard troppo purtroppo decente
speriamo che sia decente pro recco che
ti stata forte e appreso non si fanno
queste cose strane tor sorella ma dai
non ci voglio credere la gara fa corona
solo per lui
ho perso per lui varie ci rendete conto
una spada testa 129 gr duke più che però
non lo prendo lo butto sotto un camion
non ha senso di esistere porca eva
infusa nel tempo messico come come è
riuscita basta attuate giu che cazzo sei
tetris non riesce a cadere ora che mi ha
[ __ ] due spade quella le spade della
vittoria lo dico io li ho passati
governo oggi è mica un ora per finesso
livello come come spiega mi portò
filippo nato voto fumo decenti e magari
provo a fare dei bed cisco a farlo
cadere sui tubini perfetto perché la
pensavano in dott
certo nei libri pro no
ma è già qualcosa fermi tutti devo farlo
donna è un'acqua servito di morte come
sa perché c'è la vittoria pure ma che me
ne frega na vittoria voglio fare le cose
fatte basta i sistemi che alla pagina e
un giorno non s'ha da fare questo
livello
no dai tradizionali possibile aperti dai
greci
ok è uno solo fatta almeno un altro no
sono uscita mi chiami quello di prima
fantastico
ditemi se non sono il messia ragazzi
grazie grazie stato bello broker bridge
ponte rotto ma in giro meglio sismica
fonte veloce ben sa sono bravino queste
cose visto tonaca vai vai vai fratte va
in trattamento la telefonate le fratte
veloce io no
quanto al suo litico trema ma quante
nazioni di cooperative non posso
arrivare alla fine da cipro ok ma ce
l'avrà una finestra livello spero non
continuare così tutto il giorno aiuto no
no no no no no veloce perfetto
ok era una donna
prego voglio replay di questo finale vi
prego
[Musica]
gianpi e la madonna
tant'è che il padova ma che unità di
misura stai usando come fai a essere 600
km corsa i cos'è un chilometro come
fanno essere 30 600 che lei fatte le
scuole non è così la distanza a 30 km 5
milioni di chilometri un milione di
chilometri lunghezza del pene di favi
geri sopra il milione di km a quello del
sole
va bene un livello meraviglia poi mi
chiedete perché ho smesso di giocare ha
detto che queste ragazze 9 per cento il
prossimo
va bene follower mai youtube channel
cosa l'ho letto con quale grammatica
inglese me lo stai dicendo zio
beh almeno sono bravo hai e la madonna
porchera ok ha offeso doveva andare così
mi chiamano vadano avevo capito chi
sorprende sempre il suo gioco cento
impossible let's go però state tutti i
caldi che mi sono ritrovato un vetro di
due metri mezza gambe allora cosa
sostituzione ed aiuto aiuto perché era
un vetro nel coach che cazzo ma poi
anche fisica dove passato a ok sono
liberato almeno di soldi ve lo posso
prendere anche tutte le monete ok
mancano queste tre perfetto al cav hst
vinciamo pure caricando sul traguardo a
un fenomeno però va bene anche così
vincere arrivando a trovarlo perché
effettivamente
le monete non era così impossibile
adesso sì che sono contento va bene così
salvai everything air force ma reit fi
bisogna fare qualcosa a cascano delle
cose dal cielo così ho vinto bene è
stato quanto semplice perché quando
arrivavo io da piccolo a casa da scuola
e portavo i due altro che tavoli che
cadevano credeva di tutto è reso ancora
vivo del great taymor race è una roba
carina minc incredibile già perso il
casco non che mi serve a molto
ho potuto il tavolo di un altro gli olo
sopra vivo come come faccio essere
trascinati su vai verso di fili per tua
madre
kakà non riesco dai a gesù e la madonna
che è successo
vabbè dei vorrei sono fabriano
ristorante una bambina ferrari e pigiami
facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi perché mi
chiami disco di amy your car never
perché perché mappa cosa e questo è uno
dei motivi per i quali non avrò mai la
patente però dettagli va bene ma dai
ragazzi prima fare un paio di partite
super smash almeno questa volta
giocatore singolo giusto per fare figure
di merda number one sono il numero 1 in
questo discorso 9 che non è vero per
aspirin breve partirà un mero sassi
trasmesso e quel gioco dove deve
indovinare chi ap iscritti tra i due che
ti propone di voi per l'over però di
youtube quale youtuber propri iscritti
fa vj in generale però in questo caso di
topi che è il prossimo lavoro al quale
era youtuber propri iscritti
michael righini ti stimo un sacco e ti
voglio bene però in questo caso
ok con siti giallo zafra nome turn o
mito bene youtube fa cagare tensione
blur porco demonio del rapper fa erano
vestiti just di creta menchi va bene ed
extra o di host e fornire al 62 fa più
padovana al 21 c'è una sterile giorgio
cappello di paglia stesso j ax browser
clio makeup zamp ciccio game e vado nel
fenomeno
gli ho troppi ice core 10 attenzione
telefonino che cazzo telefono inutile
hdblog brava per i blog fabio vetro e
non si rompe mai battuto intelligere e
perillo a posso candidarmi anche in
politica
un grande fiuto caravaca lo sapevo va
bene è a posto
basta basta perché se vi giuro che
quando sta così mi sento un uomo nuovo
basta con la merda te quando siamo
arrivati 140 episodi basta però che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi conclude episodio
dopo esservi entrato dal giappone dovevo
darmi una botta di vita e quindi ho
giocato ha detto questo ha fatto bene
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi che
giorni momento mi piace anche dalla
stazione senza vestiti da tecnici
vediamo prossimo visto ragazzi
[Musica]